hi my name is Tom Jackson I was just
wondering in regards to what Stephen
Hawking said about something happening
in the universe for the universe to
start itself whether that provides
evidence for the theory about multiple
universes hi Tom so you're asking about
Stephen Hawking in the theory of
multiple universes to tell you the truth
again I'm not a theorist I'm measuring
things so so far we have no visual
evidence no observational evidence of
multiple universes on the other hand
since we don't know why our universe
exists we have no reason to think that
other universes can't also exist so
there could very well be in my opinion
and multiple universes but probably in a
way that we would not know that they
exist